>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, WE HAVE BEEN
SPIED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
NOT A LOT YOU CAN DO ABOUT IT.
YOU CAN SEEM OUTRAGED BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF RECOURSE.
YOU LEARN ABOUT YOUR DEMOCRACY
WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
CAN YOU FILE A FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT SEEKING ANY
CALLS OR TEXT MESSAGES THEY GOT
FROM YOU.
WE DID THAT.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD BACK FROM THE
NSA.
THEY PROMPTLY RESPONDED TO SOME
STOOGE ON A WEBSITE.
HE WROTE ON TWITTER THIS:
IT CRYSTALLIZES THE
DEGRADATION.
THEY ARE COVERING IT UP AND
CHEERING IT ON.
WHAT WILL YOU FIND IN OUR
REQUEST, FIND OUT WHAT THE NSA
IS DOING.
THAT MIGHT OCCUPY YOUR TIME.
IT DOESN'T OCCUR.
THEY SUPPORT IT.
JUSTIN IS A LAW PROFESSOR AT
GEORGE WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY AND
KNOWS A LOT ABOUT THIS SUBJECT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
I REALIZE THE REQUEST FROM THE
INTERCEPT IS EASIER.
IT DOESN'T EXPLAIN WHY THEY
FILED.
WHY NOT GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
WHAT THE NSA IS DOING?
HAS THAT OCCURRED TO ANYONE?
>> NOT FROM THE PEOPLE YOU
EXPECT TO RAISE QUESTIONS.
I JUST TESTIFIED IN THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON THE
SURVEILLANCE OF REPORTERS.
IT WAS ONE OF THE FEW TIMES IN
RECENT MEMORY THAT THERE WAS
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT WITH ALL OF
US WHO TESTIFIED AS EXPORTS.
ALL OF THE MEMBERS IN THE ROOM
AGREED WE NEEDED TO INVESTIGATE
WHEN JOURNALISTS WERE
INTERCEPTED.
THAT HASN'T BEEN THE RESPONSE TO
THIS STORY.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF WAYS YOUR
EMAIL WOULD HAVE BEEN
INTERCEPTED THAT WERE LAWFUL.
YOU COULD BE CORRESPONDING WITH
SOMEONE SUBJECT TO AN NSA
SURVEILLANCE.
BUT IT DOESN'T EXPLAIN THE MORE
TROUBLING QUESTIONS OF HOW THAT
INFORMATION WAS CIRCULATED AND
ALSO HOW YOUR NAME WAS NOT
MASKED.
YOU CAN UNMASK PEOPLE IN
SURVEILLANCE DOCUMENTS OF THAT
KIND.
BUT IT REQUIRES SOMEONE TO ASK
FOR UNMASKING.
THERE WOULD BE NO LEGITIMATE
REASON TO DO SO HERE.
IF REPORTERS WERE GIVEN THAT
INFORMATION, IT WOULD BE EVEN
MORE SERIOUS.
EVEN IF YOUR EMAIL ITSELF WAS
KNOW CLASSIFIED.
THE INTERCEPT IS.
THE NSA AND FOA MATERIAL IS
HIGHLY CLASSIFIED.
TAKES YEARS FOR ME TO GET ACCESS
TO AN NSA SURVEILLANCE DOCUMENT.
THE MERE FACT THAT THEY ENGAGED
IN SURVEILLANCE IS CLASSIFIED.
IT WOULD BE A SERIOUS FEDERAL
CRIME.
>> Tucker: WELL, YEAH.
THEY INTIMIDATE PEOPLE.
EVERYONE IS AFRAID OF THE NSA.
THE LAST ADMINISTRATION WAS
REALLY AFRAID OF THEM.
THAT'S TRUE.
I KNOW FIRSTHAND.
A LOT OF PEOPLE NOW ARE AFRAID
OF THEM.
DO YOU WANT TO LIVE IN A COUNTRY
WITH PEOPLE ARE AFRAID OF YOUR
INTEL AGENCYS?
WHY ARE WE ACCEPTING THIS?
>> ONE OF THE INTERESTING
ASPECTS OF THIS IS PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THIS WOULD BE RIDICULOUS.
IT'S NOT RIDICULOUS.
I TESTIFIED JUST ABOUT A WEEK
AGO IN THE JUDICIARY.
THERE IS ALMOST REGULARITY TO
THIS.
JOURNALISTS INVESTIGATED IN THE
BUSH ADMINISTRATION AND THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
AFTER EVERY ONE OF THOSE
SCANDALS, THERE IS THE REQUISITE
APOLOGIES AND PROMISES OF REFORM
AND EVERYONE GOES AWAY AND THEN
THE CYCLE CONTINUES.
>> Tucker: HOW ABOUT PRISON
TIME?
THEY TRIED TO SEND ROGER STONE
AWAY FOR HIS LIFE FOR
INCONSISTENT TESTIMONY, BUT
THESE PEOPLE GET MSNBC CONTRACT.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO FIX THIS ONE.
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS ON THIS.
YOU HAVE BEEN RIG